Joe Jonas and sophie Turner are
officially married again after tying the
knot in a surprise ceremony in Las Vegas
earlier this year a source tells ET that
the duo said I do for a second time on
Saturday this time in France and it was
everything they wanted it's great it's
wonderful
Sophie reportedly walked down the aisle
in a Louis Vuitton gown while Joe rocked
a tux and black undershirt according to
our source Joe and Sophie said I do in
front of family and friends after
enjoying a nice week having fun at
numerous events celebrating their union
like a white dinner held at the Hotel de
la Mer and in the South of France the
day before the wedding and an epic river
cruise complete with Priyanka Chopra and
Nick Jonas
[Music]
of course the duo also attended Joe and
Sophie's European nuptials Priyanka
stunning in a floral pink sari which she
put on full display during her own photo
shoot outside the venue even Diplo was
amongst the famous guests of course the
DJ famously and rather controversial E
live stream Sofie and Joe's first
wedding in Vegas
this time he jokingly instagrammed a
single pic with the caption this is the
only photo I got from joe and sophie
turner Jonas's wedding because they took
my phone from me and put in a holding
cell during the ceremony heard it was
lovely though but the real scene stealer
was Joe's only four-legged groomsman yes
we're talking about his dog who was
easily the best roomed of all the dapper
groomsmen in his miniature tuxedo but
nothing beats this sweet brotherly
moment Joe shared with Kevin ahead of
the ceremony he was telling me if she's
already starting to think about what
she's gonna wear to your wedding oh good
I don't know why she's thinking about
I'm getting hot the bridesmaid dress
meanwhile Sophie previously opened up to
et about the very important role her
former Game of Thrones co-star Maisie
Williams would play on her wedding day
she gonna be one of your bridesmaids yes
she's my maid of honor of course sophie
had plenty of sweet things to say about
her new hubby too it's just like the
best to pull it the best person to calm
me down and keep me calm and if I end up
crying I have a shoulder to cry on so
it's good
I'm so happy and here's what Jonah said
about falling in love with Turner and
the Jonas Brothers Amazon documentary
chasing happiness in finding myself I
was also able to find a partner the
impact of falling in love has made me
want to be a better man a better person
and ultimately made me a better brother
the famous duo got engaged in October
2017
Jonas took to Instagram to announce the
news sharing this photo of Turner's
gorgeous engagement ring with the
caption she said yes
[Music]